hello Internet today we're gonna be
playing some planetside 2 now out on
PlayStation 4 that is no longer being d
das yay we can actually play this game
finally there's like five days of that I
think Aaron Sampson Ryan schubert is
playing and what we're going to focus on
is you and I used to be big battlefield
fans we really enjoyed that model for
years and then that model got kind of
scale and we drifted off this came out
last week and we both fired it up by the
way this is a three year old game on PC
oh yeah this is a totally old pc game
okay so here's what we really love about
planetside 2 that we feel like
battlefield could pick up for starters
the large open world in planetside 2 is
really awesome it it gives you a sense
of continuity like you're there's a
sense of meaning to it right there
aren't like beginning and ends two
matches like it's a constantly
persistent open battle world that cycles
every few hours or so on each continent
but you have day-night cycles which were
witnessing sunrise here I suspect or no
we're going west maybe sunset but and
like so this idea that you just start a
match on a fixed map and you play and
then that map and that matches over that
feels like it's gotten kind of old to me
or kind of stale Call of Duty and
Battlefield have taken that model to its
logical conclusion sure and they've done
a good job of it but you know those
games need to start looking in new
directions and I think the massive open
world of planetside really is that
direction you know not that it would
have to be as largest planet side but
there's a lot of things that this open
world does it's sort of like I feel like
the sort of spiritual direction that
battlefield could have gone in and it
reminds me a lot of playing bad company
2 when you know the whole course of a
rush match would take you over hill and
valley and through the water and like
almost tell a story as you went and you
know sitting down to play this game for
an hour to gives you that too because
the map is like enormous right like this
is
a thing is that it takes place on these
continents and there are actually
several continents in the game and
there's thousands of players right and
there they're packed and what's really
cool is that there's three factions so
you're not just fighting one other
faction right like you roll into a new
territory and you can get sandwiched
between two factions or you can be
fighting a faction and they can get
sandwiched between another fashion right
absolutely it's just it adds a lot it's
incredible how much it adds having that
third group in there now not only that
but factions can lock down entire
continents and then all those people
from those servers get shifted onto your
continent or another continent so the
game just kind of naturally builds if
one continent gets taken than the other
continents heat up after that right now
the ps4 version seems to have
incorporated some of the large
improvements that I remember weren't
there when plantside to launched on PC
which is there seems to be more of like
an AI director now telling you where to
go so rather than just having players
control it the game actually recommends
what the next best places for you to
focus your forces all right and you know
when this originally launched you could
drop in not find the action and have to
drive for a half an hour to go find it
and there used to be a giant cooldown on
instant action and now all that's gone
so you can just get right in with your
team and go so there are different types
of facilities and you can get into these
cool situations where you can maybe
fight through a science lab come down
off it and get caught on a bridge and
two large tank forces couldn't get stuck
on this bridge and you need somebody
who's basically a commander to end this
game has a complete chat command
structure right to be like hey no we
need to pick up some galaxies which our
troop transports and fly over this
impasse and take the base behind them
which I've seen happen multiple times so
you have that command structure and
strategic depth that you just don't
really get in battlefield anymore
the sunders are cool they're an
improvement on say the amtracs in
battlefield because for starters they
yours something right how many times in
battlefield have you gone into a mobile
spawn point moved it somewhere perfect
and ideal get out and then a second
later somebody gets in it and drives off
with it okay that happens all the time
go time well in planetside 2 the vehicle
that you purchased is actually your
vehicle so you can spawn us under arm it
up as you please and then drive it into
battle and it's up to you to put it in a
ideal location use it right you know
it's kind of like what we talked about
with hardline how it would have been
great to have a club so people couldn't
move it there's a pretty extensive mock
tree for a lot of vehicles in this game
you can really specialize like you can
get good as a pilot like you could in
battlefield but in this case again
because the vehicles yours you get to
customize it how you like it and get
talented at using it and you can just be
a Transport Pilot in this game and
you're very useful as a transport pilot
I mean you can just shuttle troops back
and forth to different war zones or
leapfrog over an enemy impasse I will
say that the actual cost of unlocks in
this game is a little bit out of control
right you know it's got that
ten-year-old MMO subscription model
which is just really out of touch with
reality that being said you don't need
to spend money on this game no you you
will get your free to play money's worth
just with the core weapons and the core
vehicles and the sort of in-game
currency for the really basic stuff
actually isn't so bad so you can you can
play basic vanilla planetside without
the exorbitant ly ridiculous weapon
prices so it's interesting this game
being an open world does have a lot of
positives but some of the negatives can
be on occasion you can get a couple of
comments lockdown and
have like the fight kind of peter out a
little bit sure and you know that's the
thing is that this the thing that your
traditional Call of Duty or battlefield
has is that you don't really wait to get
in a gunfight in those games yeah I mean
you're literally respawning before your
old body it's the ground yeah and then
and this game you're definitely gonna it
might take a little while you also got
to think though more I like that about
this game like it it's as more of
strategic it respects your intelligence
a little bit more yeah um it's not gonna
hold your hand you're gonna have to flip
through the menus and figure stuff out
the hard way and also you know if you or
by yourself and you choose to drop it on
a force of 96 that's um another faction
like you're just not going to win I'm
gonna get anywhere it's interesting one
thing I think it used to in this game
which you and I have slightly different
opinions on is the fact that bad guys
aren't a specific color so you're the
color that you see like for example red
is is only because you're the red
faction right and you know if you're
here ven here you always see your
faction as purple and you have to get
used to you know games I've gotten to a
point where they've trained you to shoot
read a lot yes and you have to not shoot
red if you're on this faction because
red is always friendly right so the flip
side to that is you can always see the
tracer fire from the other team as the
color of that team so you can almost
instantly identify what factions
shooting at you simply by the tracers
it's kind of a mix back like you have to
get used to not shooting a color that
you're used to shooting all the time
absolutely that takes time and if if
you're making switches like we did like
where you want to find just another
server and you know switch your faction
up because I have a different faction on
each server that I play on and it's
pretty easy to forget whose side you're
on could you make that switch yeah I
think about half the time the first like
two minutes that I'm on the other server
and like
shooting my own team because I think
they're the enemy the factions become
more recognizable at night also did the
way that tracer fireworks in this game
some of the coolest thing you'll ever
see our night battles oh absolutely you
know giant tank columns and infantry all
shooting each other at night in that
although like the fire going in every
direction with the tracers is pretty
incredible I well thanks for joining us
that was planetside 2 on playstation 4
and our thoughts on how this can
potentially influence the future and
battlefield if you want to check it out
it is a free to play game out right now
where you can just play the three year
old version on PC
here in the area